so here we have a sample of vanadium so
vanadium is used to do catalysis it's
used for a whole range of different
things so vanadium isn't the third of
the transition metals and because it has
more electrons it has really quite
interesting chemistry it's also used in
nature and there are a number of
mushrooms that are vanadium rich the am
of add-ins especially is one of the
materials so here if we open we can see
it on I real is a very nice sample of
the vanadium wire so this is the
elemental vanadium and you can see it's
about 0.1 millimeters in diameter and 20
meters of it on this clip on this reel
some of its compounds are very reactive
I can remember that my lab mate Paul was
working with compound called vanadium
hexa carbonyl he got a sample it was
quite expensive and he poured it came in
a sealed metal of sealed glass vessel so
he cut open the glass and poured it out
and before his eyes it burst into flames
and disappeared